[Music]
well this is definitely not the kind of
TV movie I expected from the same people
that did High School Musical and xenon
color a friendship is probably the most
mature any of the Disney Channel movies
have ever been hell it might be the most
mature Disney's ever been considering
the subject matter
I mean before this the crowning
achievement of racial relations was
Pocahontas and Song of the South
think about that the story centers
around the girl named Piper she's living
a happy life in the 1970s while her
congressman dad is trying to fight for
equal rights in South Africa not
surprisingly Piper hears a lot about
South Africa and would love to have
somebody come and visit and it just so
happens there's a foreign student
program at school so they sign up to
take somebody from South Africa in the
only downside is they don't get a black
kid they get a white kid named Maria in
a perfect world does one mean but
coming from South Africa where there's a
huge divide and inequality let's just
say Maria's shocked that the black
people she's staying with aren't her
servants it takes a while for both of
them to get over the culture shock but
eventually Marie decides she doesn't
want to go back home and she wants to
stay obviously over time she starts to
see this family beyond the color of her
skin and she even sees the differences
between the two worlds not just how bad
things are in South Africa but how not
always great things are in America -
based loosely on a short story written
by the real Piper dellums I have to
admit I cringe at the idea of imagining
Disney tackling something like this it's
kind of like when Captain Planet tried
to talk about AIDS you just don't think
they're up to it and don't get me wrong
there are some moments that don't work
in it first of all I constantly have to
be reminded as the 70s something about
it just looks so modern and current I
have to keep reminding myself
oh yeah it's 1977 once in a while go try
on clothes and look at Records but I
don't know does it really look like me
travel back in time here it just kind of
looks like we're watching a modern
Disney Channel movie the other problem I
have is that the friendship between the
two girls seems to kind of go back and
forth a little too quickly there's one
point where Maria is taken away and
Piper's like no we got to get her back
but then maybe within the span of a day
she suddenly decides that she's too
prejudiced and that they can never
belong together and it just kind of
comes out of nowhere
even when they're getting along I don't
know they just kind of do the
traditional thing of trying on clothes
giggling and then talking about their
different cultures I don't really know
too much else about what they connect on
but with those two problems out of the
way I had to admit this is actually a
very adult kids film whenever they do
sit down and talk about race and the
different cultures and what's right and
what's not it kind of has me tugging in
my shirt collar a little bit like man
can Disney do this are they able to talk
about this in a mature way
but at the same time I do listen to them
and I believe what they're saying and
it's kind of one of those uncomfortable
situations where it's good to be
uncomfortable but even then they still
address there's a lot of problems in
America too and we're trying to get that
figured out and is there an easy
solutions there a complicated solution
it's tough for an adult to hear but
important for a kid to hear honestly to
a point where I'm kind of wondering how
many kids paid attention
I mean it's so strange because I always
say kids films need to be more adult and
they need to be more mature but for a
Disney Channel movie not much really
happens in terms of action or comedy or
slapstick or usual stuff you see in
these kind of films there's no big chase
or evil villain or pies in the face or
anything like that it's just a lot of
people sitting around talking oh not
that I want a goddamn pig chase or pie
in the face or anything like that but
that's what a lot of kids familiarised
Disney Channel films with but that stuff
obviously one fit here shouldn't be here
and at the same time I've heard a lot of
people did grow up with this movie and
they did really like it
I suppose it's hard to say whether or
not I agree 100% on the portrayal
because well I didn't grow up in South
Africa I've never been there I didn't
know how things were done or how they're
done now and I know chunks of its
history so it sounds right but again I
don't know how race relations were in
South America at the time so I don't
know if this is brilliantly simplified
or insultingly simplified to me it
sounds like they don't shy away from the
tough stuff they talk about when people
are beaten to death they talk about some
people being seen as terrorists and some
people not being seen as terrorists they
talk about white babies dying compared
to black babies dying holy this is
the Disney Channel movie I expect it to
flinch a lot more in this film but
surprisingly I listened and I listened
with intrigue
I said I don't know how authentic Lee
simplified it is but what it has to say
still sounds just meaningful and
important and Fortis need to come across
that way in a film about race relations
let alone a Disney Channel film that's
really dammit pressive i guess we can
say Zootopia wasn't the first disney
film to tackle this subject matter well
because if you look hard enough you just
might find this hidden gem
[Music]
you